everything is controlled all information
is controlled with the exception pretty
much of
Twitter because the guy who owns it is
said he's not going to censor yeah Elon
it's nice I feel like that's one thing
that I thought was that yeah maybe
that's it that's what's about censorship
is at least you feel like you
can say things uh or that things can be
shared on there because didn't do you
feel I mean as someone who writes comedy
who does this every day do you feel
Freer on
the platform now on Twitter yeah I feel
like at least if YouTube takes me down
oh look at that comedy is legal on this
platform so Elon like specifically
endorsed your right to say yeah it was
nice of we had Roseanne Bar on and she's
a I like her a lot oh dude she [__]
did so much for comedy she did so much
for women and gays and uh oh wait I saw
part of that and they uh Hollywood threw
under the [__] bus as soon as they
had a chance because they
heartless and um and so anyway she was
on my show and she wait I saw that and
they took tell me if I'm misremembering
this they took a line that she had and
they cut out all the context and put it
like on Tik Tok and it made her sound
like she was a crazy person or a vicious
person which she's not either one of
yeah she's a Jewish I mean she's born
Jewish I think she's still Jewish right
she is and so she said um yeah oh and
the Holocaust never happened right she
said sarcastic ly right of I think she
had relatives who died in it yes yeah
very obvious right right of course and
they some guy on Twitter assle Sam I
don't know what the guy's name was
something [__] or somebody he [__]
made a big deal about it from the
Minneapolis fuckle Stein yeah probably I
know them this dude just this was two
weeks after right makes a big deal about
or just put that clip and whatever no
context so then YouTube took us down
took that episode down but we got to put
it on Twitter so so that was nice at
least because it was an honest place you
know um but what I worry about is like
didn't some of these companies didn't
Twitter or Facebook didn't they get in
trouble for not letting like during
election times like not real information
being allowed to be shared yeah I mean I
don't know who would get them in trouble
they run everything and you know my
concern would be as we're getting to
this election it's very intense you know
I think they're you know very intense
people on both sides and um if you
actually had a platform that was open
for everyone to say what he or she
thinks that's a massive threat to the
[__] community and I think that the
because the truth is always a threat to
Liars that's just right it never changes
people are killed never for lying ever
they're only killed for telling the
truth you're only punished for telling
the truth people get mad is because you
told the truth everyone should know that
so I mean I don't I can't imagine the
pressure that's going to come to bear on
this company
X now over the next year I mean it you
know it's going to be without precedent
I think do you think Elon could be I
mean there could be like even an
assassination attempt on him or
something I would never speculate about
something like that but I just think
there's you can't you're a guy to Bar
what do you going to say you know you
know I I think there's going to be I
would have a food taster I mean I think
it's I think look the one the one thing
we look if you're doing a great job at
something if you're a great father great
husband great employer
great comedian you're not too worried
because you know you're doing a good job
but if you're doing a bad job and the
only beneficiary of your work is you and
everyone else is getting screwed and
they can't even afford to fill up their
truck or buy groceries and you're still
getting rich you're very worried
dictators are always worried about their
own security okay so what's the biggest
threat to you the biggest threat is
someone calling you out and so you have
to shut down any medium where that could
possibly happen so obviously Facebook is
is completely controlled Google is
completely controlled Tik Tok foreign
own company God knows what their agenda
is so really the only big platform
that's pretty not controlled with some
apparently some limits but in general
it's not controlled it's free speech is
X I agree so like there's a lot at stake
legitimate leaders don't worry about
this if I'm a legitimate leader if I'm a
good father and one of my kids is like I
want to smoke weed at The Breakfast
Table you're like you can't sorry
because I make the rules no weed at The
Breakfast Table I'm not worried about
saying that because I think I'm a pretty
good father and I think my kids think
I'm a pretty good father but if I'm a
terrible father who's abusing my kids I
can't let them say anything because the
authorities might find out I I could get
punished for what they know and that is
the same attitude that every dictator
has that's why all dictators take the
guns and impose censorship is the first
thing they do they don't want to throw
you in prison it's expensive it's
difficult they don't want to execute you
they just want you to shut up and be
obedient and Elon Musk in buying this
platform an open it up to all positions
even unpopular ones is the single
greatest threat to their hegemony to
their control and uh you know I'm not
predicting their response but I mean
it's going to be intense super intense I
can say that would you have security and
uh that sort of thing if you were him
would you have like somebody you know
would you make sure that the Tesla truck
which is supposed to have been out for
17 years but that it has extra
bulletproof in the glass I would
definitely include as a standard feature
not an add-on
the oil tanks that drop the oil onto the
road behind you so the people pursuing
you spin out and like go right into a
bridge of butman or off the side of the
mountain off M Holland you know what I
mean I would definitely do that and I'd
have like hidden machine guns under the
side view mirrors I'd have a death ray
possibly that would probably be a custom
feature but I would I would have stuff
like that yeah for sure what things do
you think shouldn't be on
Twitter I mean I think everything should
be allowed on Twitter I mean I'm on
Twitter because everything is allowed
right um I don't think everything is
allowed on Twitter I haven't found the
boundary yet but but Elon Musk honet has
said he's for free speech and if it's a
political view that most people don't
like it's still allowed yeah and I'm so
grateful for that as someone with
unpopular views you know well didn't
they have well one thing that I don't
like on Twitter sometimes you see like
people beating up teachers and stuff
like that you ever seen any of this
violence that happens I don't like it
but the fact that they allow it and kids
beating up each other like those things
where somebody's going to set up a
somebody's filming some other kids like
are going to come in and beat up the kid
right um but why do they because then I
feel like if they would stop allowing
that then because other kids just start
mimicking what they see well it's so so
bad it's bad for you to watch it I say
someone who's watched a lot of it it's
like the Isis videos do you know what I
mean or there's a whole bunch of
channels of criminals getting shot
coming into a jewelry store or a liquor
store and some Korean guy just blows
them away and you can't can't help but
love it I mean it is the most alluring
kind of porn you just watch it again and
again this guy getting killed yeah and
you think this is not good for me
actually I shouldn't watch this yeah
there's probably part of your spirit or
whatever totally it's not edifying it's
it's like actually bad but it's very
hard have you ever seen the criminals
getting killed oh yeah yeah I've seen a
couple of them there's one guy who's so
good at it he's killed like seven
criminals yeah he he's a watch maker in
la oh is he yeah no it's a very famous
guy oh there's the one guy I'm like dude
they got to quit trying to Rob this guy
well he finally gave up and now I think
he lives in Vegas but this was in the
80s or 90s in La I think he killed five
people literally but I was thinking yeah
what I don't like about those vi like
the violence that they show on Twitter
where it's like the children beating up
children yeah is because if you're a kid
and you see that and you see it gets a
lot of traction then you just go do it
so you're just replicating this V like
that it's like you see so many more kids
doing it now because they've seen it as
like a thing like so that kind of thing
I don't think they should allow one
there well also you don't want to see
every ugly thing that people
do you know what I mean yeah you don't
want to see fat people in the shower you
don't want to see people on the John
like there are a lot of things that
happen that you don't necessarily want
to look at video of I don't mind
watching a thick person in the shower if
there's a real skinny person there with
them and they have to like kind of like
jockey for position or something you
know hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
bring you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this
one